welcome to this video yet again giving
the opponent more than 20 extra seconds
I got a phone call right after at this
started the game ok i'm playing a king's
indian at least yeah it's mostly closed
positions so maybe i can get in more
yeah we play some quick a moves to to
get to catch him on the clock that's
what i was trying to say ok cf5 i'm
trying for calif banco gambit c55 be
five ok he's taking his time the natural
Master dashi from Egypt yep Egypt
now really that early when Queen d2 or
92 is not exactly revolutionary ok so
the Bangko the banco in the damage ok i
can take now i can first use the night
over to e5 if i go 97 that is night h2
though ok a night h3 not h 2 all right
okay let's let's do that black does not
necessarily wants to take on b5 there's
also Knight e5 queen before night c4 as
a possible idea okay so he's so trying
to prevent me from taking all together
this means i need to focus on the
mentioned other idea yes this is
possible maybe it's even good
you have to get the knight to f3 this
should help him ok let's flick this in
and what now now maybe Queen to b4 night
c4 still Jam I probably played this
really badly ok if he goes e5 I can take
d 595 22 and 95 at the end it's probably
ok so we cannot go e 5 and now queen
here so sometimes they're really wacky
Queen traps and stuff but I don't see it
ok
maybe now I can even consider now again
to take on b5
24 hangs of course not hmm Wow well I'm
over looking many moves in the scam that
will probably cost me at the end right
here smells okay if I take here that's
not the problem Queen takes my queen has
very little very little squares look
here queen bee three and okay m94 snot
on okay i need to do it but what's hot
hot else
94 causes threatened rook a phone yeah I
have this i have the square only the
square yeah you can force it wrong but
really I don't oh wait if he goes rook a
for I have 94 look a for I have night a
nightie form that's funny then then I'm
not not bad in this position at all the
this hangs and I'm threatening to take
on b5 yeah that's the weird stuff about
the Kings Indian and benoni sometimes it
out of the blue we you sometimes really
have important resources okay he gave up
this bishop probably he wants to play be
6m it's not bad at all yeah I don't know
maybe I should have taken mmm should
reform yeah dunno
it feels like white should win somehow I
mean he has this pawn won't be six this
is probably sufficient to win but it
feels like there should be something
really decisive okay I want to get this
into play this bishop oh ok we cannot
move the night as a for hangs oh I have
a phone know if I can take with the rook
I cannot move this ok whoo yeah you can
still force those drawers but I don't
really see how should how to avoid it
but now I think you really should force
the draw with this this kind of time
situation it's their way to to play on I
don't I don't see it
no crazy stuff
the only way to play on is to let the
clock run down to two less than 28 and
then gamble hoping that he avoids the
draw then I can try that let's say it's
of course with a bit cute okay now let's
see if he still repeats no it doesn't
time warning check
i blundered this check check hiya Scott
check so no jack check white for Vince
oh yeah I wanted to hear I thought this
is the only way to continue provoke him
to play on but young thatís was very
hairy stuff I mean this is the Queen
Queen they're probably there's a win
somehow if you if you give it to the
computer it will probably tear this
apart one minute and one but one pawn
it's giving 94 here is an interesting
news yeah yeah that's not its not so
stupid as I'm taking on b5 at the end
like this and this year's the pin that's
not so not so out of this world okay but
I just repeat it and the idea was that
if he goes this and then this is winning
even because now the rook is hanging and
why the suit is losing so we must play
this and if I if you have and known as
this this must be winning four wide yeah
it is it is a win simply because of the
palm and okay we had yet
the computer likes right all along
teehee he had the situation where I just
let the clock run down to provoke him to
continue which is of course really
gamble because it's still clear that
black is in trouble though I just wanted
to fight ok now that sets its ok yeah I
get all the pawns and I was in good
shape around him hmm yeah I didn't see
that he can take with the rook of course
and this is just just funny jarek we
continue and probably lost but ok didn't
even count the material it's only i it's
it's it's a peaceful upon yeah so this
was the only way to to win it time time
of course bottom i have even regained
the PCM yeah a good good fight this game
thanks for watching